how are you I'm very happy my feet hurt
yeah yeah why do your feet hurt because
I don't know but I went to the you know
what on San Vicente that's that's no yes
we live near each other I know we've
seen this place I walked in there to the
sneaker store oh oh I know that sneaker
long runners or something yeah yeah so
like I said my feet hurt to the guys and
they say yeah you should change your
sneaker I said what's good for me and
they said these yeah so I feel better oh
you feel better now because your your
feet were hurting they were killing me
yeah I think uh this is not do your feet
hurt ever uh sometimes my knees hurt
more than my feet hurt I I had knees and
it's moving I'm like
I'm suddenly in a nursing home
no it hurts when I go to the bathroom
this is an infomercial for mineral life
yeah yeah how many times a night you go
into the bathroom well it depends it
depends I would say you know sometimes I
can get through with one but sometimes
it's two occasionally it's three yes
yeah and then I'm like why has my body
betrayed me you know if I get it when I
get a one I am so relaxed and I'm like
look at that one and I'm so happy in the
morning when I get a two I'm a little
mad in the morning when I get a three
I'm like I I'm just such a bad mood yeah
yeah because you don't you can't fall
back asleep right right yeah that's it
oh yeah yeah yeah this is a terrible
line of conversation yeah here's what I
want to talk to you about because I saw
you like two weeks ago yeah and um I
hope you oh yeah I do yeah I think
you're going to remember this I was in
New York where I was back there I was
going to go to Boston to see my folks
but I stopped off in New York right and
my wife and my kids and I are staying in
this hotel and I go down and it's a
really nice hotel and I go down and I'm
sitting in there to have breakfast in
the morning and I'm with my kids and all
of a sudden I see this guy who I didn't
realize was in town with his kids right
I guess also for Thanksgiving to see
some shows yes and your wife you come
walking in wearing a t-shirt and uh some
gym shorts
no shoes or socks yeah you came walking
in like this and you were Barefoot into
a restaurant I know which is illegal I
know and and I'm like no one else did
and everyone else was like Mr Sandler
how are you and you're like I want
coffee
what was that what was that all about
look here's the deal when I my I'm very
stiff my body's stiff I can hardly Bend
anymore yeah so to put on my sneakers it
hurts so so I said that's why you got
kids
oh my God put the shoes on Daddy and
they're like No And so I said that Daddy
goes out Barefoot and then I did I can't
do that you can't go into I know you're
a big deal but you were walking around
and I noticed like literally a society
women were like oh you know it was
ridiculous it felt silly when I was in
the elevator I was like no big deal
shoes are off this makes sense I think I
probably did it a lot at Howard
Johnson's when I was five and so I I was
like the same feeling as that and then
once the doors open I saw a Lobby I was
like oh I'm already committed to this
yeah and I'm Barefoot and my kids kind
of even my nice kids even looking like
he didn't shoes and I was like Hey relax
and uh then I like the way you depict
how you speak to your children yeah shut
up you
relax pipe down or I'll give you another
one it was a dumb my uh but these
sneakers are incredible oh good you got
the secrets you want to give them a
shout out I don't even know it's hookah
or Haka I don't know Manner
and uh yeah they're just soft well just
keep them on okay all right